the thing that I love about Derby is I
forget everything around me when I'm
playing every one of us kind of have
nicknames so my nickname around there be
as shiny tiny because I'm tiny I'm short
and I had this like bling users like
shiny tiny and my friend Karima from
Egypt we called her kitty majima because
she's really good
I just love it and this is something I
think I would never stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one young man when you know zero Egypt
sorry
my name is hadith Qureshi I'm from Yemen
I came to Lebanon year and a half ago I
came here for a scholarship to have my
studies in college in AUB I have my my
friends are also like part of throw the
Derby who are like from Egypt from
Bahrain from Tunis and we are like a
family here by the way was very weak as
blockers we shouldn't even move it
should be I know no it's a good job yeah
it was something I didn't expect that I
will have here and Beirut I didn't
expect that have real Derby in my life
know if you I feel felt down on your
behind this just stand up and keep going
when we had the first official game and
we went to my lab Beirut like a kind of
the public field and we were like doing
actually against each other because
there are no other team to compete oh I
wouldn't say we're really that extremely
professional
but we're improving in a crazy way and
by the end of the day more people wants
to join
that was the time when like you know it
hit us that this is the first team in
Lebanon we actually started the face
roller derby team here in baby
three two one coming you're good
kitty my try to lean on me and you just
simply don't care about me you just like
push yourself ok I'm not try to help you
as well to go faster why you need to
tell me what side ok
say okay again
I have so many moments during my day
that goes back and forth from BMN to
here
[Music]
it makes me actually live in a conflict
within myself like how I can be happy
while my family are suffering being here
at the beginning especially like the
first months I was able to be in touch
with them anytime it was way easier and
it happened so fast we didn't see it
coming it was just out of a sudden my
can return to be in a war and my family
are being bombed our home it's kind of
close to the presidential house back in
here man and that was like one of the
main targets now that no electricity no
water like jobs stopped and the bombing
is crazy and like the whole house would
shake my sister she should have in
another neighborhood the ones she's
married her house was destroyed I used
to listen to news a lot and like follow
what's happening but it's frightening
even through Facebook it was just
frightening because all I hear is just
bad stories and I don't know what is
happening at the moment or what just
like my family are going through
[Music]
you
[Music]
at the beginning I would decide that I'm
not going to practice because I'm just
depressed and I'm saying my oh man I
don't want to see anyone but then I see
everyone is going on be like okay I'll
just go anyway I'll just put my
headphones on and I would just put and
talk to anyone just go skate and come
back you know it's just like as a
mission and once I get there and I'm on
skates I just start laughing I didn't
notice that until after I don't like it
just happens it makes me happy makes me
hyper I fall and I laugh an important
part of my life is my family
they've always were like with me support
me to continue my education and to
follow my dreams and goals especially in
Yemen not a lot of families like that
especially for me as a girl they
wouldn't let girls to go out much or to
know that queer she's going what she's
doing with who like no phone no internet
notice you're still young you still do
that which are you watching our our
relationship is based on trust so even
for me I don't want to do something like
wrong or bad because I'd rather have
faced anything in my life rather than to
break the trust that my dad and my mom
gave me I do things that I think not
anyone else I myself think that it is
right I feel it's me I'm being myself
[Music]
[Music]